[Music]
we do we are who we are okay so let's
play e4 playing grigor georgiev
so he plays the french now i've
experimented in the french with various
lines
and this time i'm going to play the
taurash this is what i play as my actual
main line now in the torah
it's sort of a version of the advanced
french where white builds up this pawn
chain and black attacks it
now the reason we put the knight on d2
and not c3 is because i now have the
move c3 which defends the pawn
now where does the bishop belong here on
which square would the bishop be most
active in this position
yeah we can do something tomorrow all
right your bishop d3 is correct
and uh now knight gf3 to depend upon
and this is where things kind of get
cool this is still theory
um why not bishop b5 is something i'll
explain
afterward and he goes f6 now this move
is kind of a famous mistake
the drawback of this move is that it
creates this diagonal
for my queen and i want a queen to get
on h5 so what i need to do here is
distract him
in order to get my queen h5 distract him
often means sacrifice
by sacrificing something we're able to
to divert his attention
away from needing to defend against
queen h5 so what sacrifice would do that
yeah i'll talk through everything after
the game we haven't had many french's i
know that
i haven't fully explained the ideas for
for each side knight g5 here is correct
there's more to this than that logic
there's a lot of variations but this is
a famous move
um which leads to a lot of complications
knight d takes e5 is black's best
response here
opening up the d7 square for the king if
he takes on on g5 i go queen h5
and his king gets into a lot of trouble
that's not the end of the story there's
a lot of variations there
i don't actually know all of them but
the logic
verbally should be clear to people i
want to go queen h5 because
never play f6 and he can't castle
because his bishop obstructs
his king from escaping um
why is knight g5 an effective move that
distracts him because the knight also
attacks e6
so he needs to attend to that and in
attending to that he cannot also defend
against queen h but if that makes sense
um but but the bottom line is i want a
queen on h5 and i want to do it with
tempo if i move my knight let's say to
h4
that would be a telegraphed pass as we
say in basketball okay so he
decides to defend e6 but he does allow
queen h5
and um it's sort of one bad thing or the
other bad thing actually that's
okay so this is where a lot of people
slip up because
there's a lot of tempting moves it's not
entirely clear which of them we should
prefer knight f7 here is super tempting
but that's not the end of the story
because if we go knight f7 he actually
goes queen e8
i want people to pay very careful
attention to this okay
and what happens then is that our queen
is going to be pinned our knight is
actually going to be pinned so we don't
actually want to play knight f7 here we
want to basically say this okay
he's already moved his gang out which is
good so we can decide between a couple
of things but
the simplest is just to drop our knight
back to three there's nothing wrong
with just saying look his king is super
weak
his position is bad i'm not going to
deal with any of the complications that
arise after moves like 96 or 907
i'm just going to play the russian
school of chess brings the knight back
very very slow a lot of people get into
trouble because they assume
i have to have a win here let me spend
three minutes trying to find a win
they don't see anything they get
frustrated and they go for a move anyway
it's totally fine to make a modest move
and basically
celebrate or small victory so now what's
going on he does have a connected
protected passer on d5 but because it's
the middle game i don't really care
our plan now obviously we don't we don't
want to trade queens because we're
attacking
is to complete our development which
means we need a castle and we need to
bring this bishop out this bishop is
blocked by the knight so where can we
put this knight
such that the knight also accomplishes
something and get this bishop what
square
would we potentially put the knight on
and what would the knight be doing on
that square
what would the knight yeah so knight v3
potentially aiming for d4 but first
let's castle
you guys already know the square in
front of a past or isolated pawn
should be blockaded now do we need to
defend this pawn here's a clear try this
on for size do we need to defend this
pawn or can we play an ip3
so what should you notice here in this
position if you've been practicing
tactical awareness as i have suggested
the king and the queen ladies and
gentlemen are on the same diagonal
okay that everybody should notice that
which means that if he moves his knight
away and we take that knight
we'll be able to pin him in the end but
that's not even the main reason the main
reason is the e-file getting opened
is going to be a disaster frame that's
going to be worth the sacrifice so he
sees it
uh let's get the bishop out to f4 not
because we're defending the pawn but
because
we're creating an x-ray against this
king that's the main reason we're
putting the bishop on f4
also it's good to defend but how should
we continue deploying our pieces
such that they basically prepare for
attack prepare slowly attack fast we
don't need to play knight d4 yet
let's play rook c1 for now let's see
what he does and we can also put the
knight on c5 that's also super active
square but
i like the move knight d4 because it
exploits the pin
where can this knight go from d4 yep he
allows it where can this knight go now
yeah we can go for this beautiful
outpost on d6
he's done a really good job getting his
king to relative safety
but he's done that at the cost of all of
these positional things and
king on b8 is not going to be safe
forever we're eventually going to use
our pawns
to uh kick away some of his pieces
and i think the c file is going to be
what we're going to use
to ultimately get to him yeah that
square is amazing so
when i say we're going to use our pawns
to kick away his pieces what
specifically do i mean by that what move
am i referring to here
yeah so we're going to play before
there's a pretty complicated reason why
knight takes b4
is bad if he plays it i mean you'll be
able to see
and that reason relates to the knight on
before being unprotected
um and if you look at the whole board
you'll notice the x-ray that the queen
is exerting on the night
uh whenever there's an x-ray like that
you should be thinking discover
checks or discovered attacks and so
we'll eventually have the move bishop g5
beautiful guys you all see it now a lot
of people here would just mindlessly
play a4
now there's a really really cool oh look
at this variation we're going to play a4
but not mindlessly because here's the
thing he's probably going to take the
pawn
no he's not okay he kind of acquiesces
but i would i'll show you guys what
happens after he takes the pawn
okay how should we proceed oh think
about it
how should we proceed
so i'm actually going to give you guys a
crazy thought
let's not play rook c1 yet let's first
take away the c6 square from his pieces
because here's the thing if he plays a
takes b5 a takes b5
we might immediately put the rook on a1
which is a newly opened file
this is simply more flexible and you
guys know the expression by now the
threat is stronger than its execution
guess what
i am going to put the rook on a1 and the
reason i'm going to do that is because
there's a knight there
and c1 is a little bit better defended
by his pieces
the squares along the c pile are better
defended by his pieces because it's
closer to his pieces the a file on the
other hand is like the wild west
now we can go bishop e3 and skewer his
knights
all right so okay so he does a good job
trying to
trade the knights but he doesn't have
enough resources to make it happen what
can we do
what can we do so look at this knife for
a second this knight is a type 2
undefended piece
which means if we apply pressure on it
and then this knight moves away
it's going to be entirely undefended so
we can actually play the move bishop to
e3
putting pressure on the knight if he
takes this one we are not going to take
with a pawn
that would open up his bishop it
wouldn't blunder the rope because we
attacked the queen
but we take this one because now you
guys can see that the a7 square is under
our control
uh now we start looking for various
checkmating ideas we also need to bring
the queen into the attack
queen a4 is actually not very possible
because of knight takes b6 but where can
we put the queen
so that we both defend the bishop and
sort of
aim indirectly at the a5 where can we
put the queen yeah we can play queen d4
i don't really like partying with the
bishop but you know partying with it
involves the queen on b6 that would be
pretty crushing so he has to choose
between several equally unappealing
options later we can bring the bishop
back before playing queen a4 we can also
play bishop a7 check
um in these positions as i've emphasized
in various points
uh there's usually multiple ways to
finish the attack
and you kind of have to choose it's
often a matter of taste
and you shouldn't be obsessed with
necessarily finding the best
option or assume that there's only one
you should try to be precise but
uh you should do that without you know
losing on time or anything like that
there's always a balance if that makes
sense okay bishop f8 is a good move he's
stopping our bishop from dropping back
to c5
we can still go to a7 oh he'll be joe
with another five we can go to a7
um that's possible and actually not only
is that possible that's what we're gonna
do
let's drag the king to c seven
and how do we keep pursuing the king how
do we keep pursuing the king
um rook c1 is correct very good guys
now look at this beautiful square ah
don't we want to rook on this beautiful
square let's get bishop e6 back in
so that we can pave the way for the rook
that comes to c7 now notice our back
rank
our back rig is not an issue queen
before if we might miss that one
but no problem just retreat our queen
it's okay
we just retreat our queen that's the
thing a lot of people struggle they see
a move like this they panic
we don't actually need to panic now
we're going to create some love for our
king
and um let's bring our bishop back so he
can't take it
he's actually done a really good job
defending he's still losing but i have
to give him some kudos
let's take b7 this is completely lost
though uh his position just collapsed
now where can we put our queen
to angle at his king which square can we
put our queen on
why don't you guys let me know okay
queen h6 yeah [ __ ]
he's going to lose on time but uh he's
completely lost here maybe i did an
attack in the best possible way but
that's another thing that you should
bear in mind when you put pressure on
your opponent
throughout the entire game uh you put
him under so much pressure that it takes
time
to defend against these threats it takes
time to defend well that's the thing in
classical chess also
that was a really nice game now the
tarash is knight d2
knight c3 is more popular that's sort of
the main line
but 92 is what i play the broad you know
cost benefit analysis here indicates
that we can play c3 later
which builds up that pawn chain on the
other hand we block the development of
the bishop so there's a
clear plus and a minus to this move and
um
we played according to theory up until
this point f6 i think is is a
considered a mistake because of knight
g5 and there's some really complicated
lines here
which i don't want to delve into too
much but i'll just show you guys one
one cool idea so after fd queen h5
and um after g6 we can take on g6
and go queen g6 and now if i remember
correctly i might be wrong here
uh why not bring the dark squared bishop
out before that night that's a good
question so why
why are we even bringing the knight out
because he's technically attacking the
pawn of shalama
so we can play bishop e3 but we blunder
the pawn so sadly
we have to attend to the pawn so
that means you know we can't develop an
eye in an ideal fashion if we could yeah
we would definitely play bishop e3
so bishop d3 is a legitimate move but
what happens then is he takes
and he uses this bishop to develop his
pieces with tempo
so he gets this little edge in
development and then he strikes in the
center uh this is a legitimate variation
but white doesn't have any advantage
here another five bull oh yolo sapien
three gifted
you guys are spoiling me as always thank
you yolo safety and chess genie pdx
lion and dark dark and chris loving the
hype folks does that make sense
yeah so basically there's a lot of finer
theoretical points that i'm not telling
you guys
it's all before thank you which is like
92 is more popular here
this is the old school move and
basically
i can explain why like 92
is usually played rather than knight f3
the old school reasoning there's two
main reasons that people of the old
school
play 92 the first is they thought this
knight could go to f3
and that would open up the pathway for
the bishop and it would
it would protect the pawn right which is
super important that's number one number
two
black has this very typical idea in the
french which looks psycho but it's
actually very common which is g5 g4 are
you
kidding me another five james barnett 93
five gifted
damn girl five gifted another
another bomb thank you appreciate it so
much james burnett
and this could dislodge the knight from
f3 and by dislodging the knight
the pawn on d4 loses its support and you
guys might be looking at this and saying
bro like what's the big deal i can just
take on c5
why are we trying to hog the spawn on d4
well that breaks up the pawn
chain okay and that creates a weakness
on e5
so black can take c5 and then we'll have
a very hard time defending this bond
does that make sense our center
collapses
and um therefore we need to keep the
pawn chain intact
but according to modern theory none of
these ideas are that scary like g5 can
be met with h3
and black doesn't get g4 in it it's just
not that simple also this is a very
weakening move
thank you thailand appreciate it i don't
know if that makes sense anyways
knight b6 is sort of an admission of
defeat check
no knight back to f3 so that's the piece
of advice i have
which is that um if you if if the
tempting move results in a mess
remember that you can just accept the
small victories in the position
and save time by making a quiet move
thank you james barnett himself
something
the knight of 728 pins our queen
and um this you guys can see i think
appreciate that this is a mess
maybe he wins the night maybe i win the
rook um
and oh yeah yeah i forgot to elaborate
so in this position after
g6 takes king e7 we use the sort of the
wish list thing
what do we want to achieve here
ultimately we're two pieces down
because somebody pap studio thank you
could somebody tell me what is like the
number one item on our wishlist here
we want what piece on what square
yeah there's a lot of a lot of bishop
takes g5 is basically checkmate it wins
a million pieces
so we need to apply the same logic that
we applied
when playing knight g5 we need to
distract him somehow and in the time
that he's distracted
we get the bishop out to g5 so what move
seems maximally distracting
bingo exactly so this knight is
centralized
the knight itself controls a lot of
squares he kind of has to take it
and now bishop takes g5 is crushing it's
technically not checkmate you can give
up all of his pieces
but now he's just down a queen so
uh i think according to theory this is
not winning for white black has some
counter sacks
i don't want to delve into it but i
think that this is good for white i'm
not positive though
but that's basically the idea the reason
we don't take the rook here
is because black would have two pieces
for a rook and we would basically give
black a chance
to bring some defenders into the game
and this position would be unclear
now chris capp asks what about knight
takes h7 at which point
well knight takes h7 it's still it's
black to move and black can get his
bishop out connecting the queen to the
rook
and again we're pinned winning only upon
here is
is not the point we're striving for more
than that also remember something
there's still a battle going on on the
western front the western front is
punching
this pawn chain is still liable to
collapse let's not forget about that so
if this attack doesn't work
uh we might not have enough resources we
might not have the time to bring our
resources
back in time to defend this pawn chain
it collapses and then it's anybody's
game
um does that kind of make sense also as
akilah points out if we castle king's
side
guess what we've opened the h file for
black so the
winning the pawn just isn't sufficient
that's why i brought the knight back to
f3
sorry because we also defend the pawn
chain
okay yeah it's only to get a tempo
otherwise black has time to defend so he
takes everything of course we don't
trade queens
now we castle we complete our
development knight be bringing the
bishop out
rook ac one bringing the rook into the
game knight d4 everything here is very
very straightforward
now we bring the knight to a very juicy
square and hear the move before
knight takes b4 as you guys already
pointed out this knight is being x-rayed
and it's type 1 undefended
so bishop g5 attacks the queen exposing
the attack on the knight
winning a piece believe it or not the
move a4 has exactly the same
logic but it takes a little bit of
finessing so knight takes e4
how do we deconstruct this position
here's what i see i see the knight on a4
not only 4 is type 1 undefended it's
also x-rayed by the queen
there's just a one problem with the
x-ray the pawn on before is blocking the
x-ring
so we go b5 incidentally the move b5
attacks the knight which means he has to
attend to that he
takes but we still don't want to move
the bishop because now the pawn defends
the knight what do we want to do first
here
yeah knight takes exactly we attack the
rook black has to attend to that and now
finally we go bishop g5 with the same
idea as with the knight on b4
queen has to move and we win the night
so
photochest thank you for the another
raid 106 but that's still not the whole
story
believe it or not that's still not the
whole story because the x-ray actually
fails
what move does black have here i always
tell you guys thank you maria when
there's a discovered attack
you need to check whether the piece
that's defended sorry whether the piece
that's attacked
can cannot move and defend the other
piece queen b4
actually defends so what do we need to
do first to stop
queen b4 with tempo and then we finally
will be ready for bishop g5
amazing sequence in my opinion we need
to go back to d6
attack the rook again block the queen's
pathway
and now we go bishop g5 and attack the
knight so it's a long sequence
but i hope i've made every step of that
clear
all of it with tempo is super important
otherwise black could defend
that's a nice line which means he can't
take he has to drop it back
and here believe it or not the move rook
c1 check which a lot of people wanted to
play kind of plays into his hands
because it helps him
make his king safer and i had already
anticipated potentially bringing the
rook to a1
so b5 blocking his his access to the c6
were making this knight super passive
now we get the rook to a1 we bring the
bishop back to e3 in order to open up
the file for the queen the rank
and also to tie ourselves to the b69 he
takes this one i take that one
he brings the knight back we get the
queen into the game if he takes
we'll have access to the a7 square
that's absolutely deadly
bishop f8 bishop a7 anyway we chase his
king around and now
we bring his king to e8 go rook c7
infiltrating this is like the final
stage of the attack i didn't play this
perfectly
but it was good enough um pawn to b6 was
double-sided because i thought about
this the problem is we'd have a hard
time bringing the bishop into the game
and he basically does the same thing he
does in the game i guess we can go
through b8 but that would take some time
you see what i'm saying
thiaminoid with the tier 2 sub thank you
so bishop b6 infiltrating we're not
trading queens
making some luft for the king thank you
sue 19.
and finally we simply take the pawn and
deploy the queen into the attack
we're threatening various sacrifices
white black is completely lost here
i could have found better ways to attack
i don't want to delve into that too much
um why not bishop g5 to attack and clear
the row asks
the atom 34 i'm assuming you're
referring to this position
well the problem is we need to recapture
a piece right he's just captured a
knight so we need to recapture
um so we need to find the middle ground
here i know it's it's weird to find the
middle ground these days
uh that word is not used much in society
but
in chess you sometimes do need to find
the middle ground um
so bishop a7 or c1 and bishop e6 uh
also bishop c5 would be good just
trading bishops and then
getting the queen over to the c file so
i hope i've
kind of made everything clear i'm
omitting some key details
i'm omitting some key details but i i
hope that i've partially explained the
logic behind the attack thank you
for the prime and uh any questions guys
any questions
yeah so rook c1 was possible there
yeah it's minus 1.6 but if you if you
let it think for a while i think it
changes its evil
i think that's a common thing yeah i
agree that it's complicated but
i hope that people can still trace the
logic uh the variations are complicated
because that's what chess is
but jam jam another five girl
but everything we did is relatively
straightforward in its intention
it's just justified by relatively
complicated lines
and um hopefully i made that relatively
clear
okay let's play the next game thank you
for the five gifted gem jim
let me write down game two
okay let's go
yeah i know and that's why you practice
calculation calculation is is a way of
getting your logic to work
okay let's go with another e5 exo start
that guy watches my stream
so let's play the two knights defense
against the karo khan which
is kind of a thematic way of responding
to the car gun the yolo sapien another
five
amazing and here okay
so this is a legitimate variation let's
go bishop to c4
wow paul kellerman that wasn't it wasn't
a very good guy
and let's tickle the bishop let's see
what it wants to do
and uh white's play here is very
straightforward we simply develop okay
so he takes we take back we have two
bishops now
quite nice now we need to get our king
back
and we need to develop what should we do
here let's be very careful
uh black has a bit of an annoying idea
that we want to prevent
we can prevent it of fannie o'daniel 10
subs
raising the stakes d4 to stop 95 amazing
guys thank you so much
what the hell amazing now what's castle
we don't we don't have to worry about
knight takes c4
incredible guys yeah so he can take and
go knight f6 that's typical
now we need to find a good place for our
queen
where should we put our queen here who
can who can tell me a solid nice square
so it doesn't block the development of
any other pieces
so some people so queen h4 would walk
into bishop e7
queen f3 would blunder the pawn queen d3
does everything queen e3 would obstruct
the bishop queenie two would blunder the
pawn we could sacrifice the pawn
but i'm not really in the mood for that
i want to keep things simple and white
is slightly better here we have the two
bishops
black's position is also super solid so
this is going to be a um thank you so
much tricky this is going to be a long
game
and we got to be very patient here so
let's
where should we bring our bishop this is
where things get a little bit tricky
so bishop f4 is where i know a lot of
people want to put it
but let's consider what he does after
bishop f4 he goes bishop d6
and he trades off another pair of pieces
and i don't want to give away my two
bishops
so that's where i say not every one of
your pieces needs to be
devising a way to distribute the kobe
vaccine we just developed the bishop is
the bishop amazing not necessarily but
it's perfectly decent on d2 it's still
controlling the diagonal
and at least we preserve our two bishop
advantage i know some people are
thinking it's passive but
remember that peace placement for the
most part is temporary
um it's okay to have one of your pieces
not be it
at its maximal activity uh at any given
point in the game
so let's go a4 now to grab some space on
the queen side and then you can see in
case he castles queen side
we'll kind of be prepared to to attack
him with pawns
we're sort of preemptively trying to
discourage him from castling queenside
picasso's king side this move will still
be healthy because we've grabbed some
space on the queen side nothing wrong
with that at all
he he actually raised our queen who can
tell me what we should do in this
position
it would be a nice idea here to
reposition the queen to get out of the
x-ray
where should we put it yeah rockefeller
was possible also
yeah queen queen f3 is good yeah queen
if the queen g3 would bond to the queen
queen c3 would be a little bit awkward
i'll explain the full decision logic
behind this move after the game
but um there is also a very specific
tactical reason behind this move
hopefully he will allow us to explain it
he doesn't okay now
it would be a good idea perhaps to
deploy our bishop through f4 although he
can go back to d6 and we might have to
bring the bishop back again
so how should we defend the spawn
instead
what would be a very robust way yes c3
defending the pawn with the pawn
as i've explained many times that
usually is the best way to defend
particularly an important pawn
we're preserving our advantage we're
nurturing it we're bringing our pieces
to better squares
i wouldn't rush to make a plan here uh
let's see how he positions his pieces
and that will inform us more about how
we should position ours
okay so let's unpack this mode for a
second he's attacking the pawn
the move b3 would defend the pawn
but it would also weaken the c3 square
so let's play bishop b3 instead because
that way we maintain control and we
maintain the sort of health ah that's
another movie mate
i actually missed this move uh but
that's okay
because
sadly we're gonna have to blink queen to
d1 bringing our queen back in order to
not allow him to take the pawn that's
okay
the position is robust enough to where
uh we don't have to worry about
having to make a move like that it's
okay uh not ideal and he plays a very
very good moment in turn this guy's
playing super super well okay so because
we have the two bishops we're going to
open up the position
um but he's got an annoying atm that's
actually not that good
he's got rook takes d2 as a big threat
he's got rook takes c2 has a very big
threat
um so let's let's do some damage control
here
we gotta go rookie two we gotta we gotta
redefend the bishop of the rook
i don't like the fact that he's pinning
us but we can get out of the pin with
quincy to the next move
um he learned from my speedrun right no
no white is fine here uh white is
completely fine
it looks a little ugly it's a little
iffy but i don't see
a concrete way for him to actually make
something of this his pieces
are active but we're going to try to
push them away now what are what are our
ideas here
look at this h7 square very carefully
what idea can you propose guys to
try to exploit that square being weak
and to try to exploit our queen being on
c2 bingo we can reposition our bishop to
b1
creating a battery now you guys might
look at this what's the utility of that
battery
if the knight's defending that square
well that ties down his knight
and i've explained on several occasions
that tying down
one of his pieces could be good both
positionally tactically he takes it out
of the game
and also it creates the potential for
tactics that exploit the knight and i
could get overloaded
imagine that he assigns the task uh the
knight another task
an overloading tactic could result from
a situation like this that's another
really really good move
let's get our bishop to e5 let's try to
remove that knight from the board so our
queen could gain access to the h7 square
hopefully everything i'm doing is making
sense
okay so he's probably going to do this
uh we're not going to make a dryer
let's bring our bishop back to c1 for
now let's let's uh take a take a chill
pill and let's see how he positions his
pieces let's continue
trying to get this knight off the board
uh that's basically what this game
revolves around
okay so we can make a marginal
improvement to our position by doubling
rooks just bringing this rook to a
slightly better square
uh g4 would be two weakening i will
after the game spell out my logic in
this position but
i'm trying to explain every move for now
we're just trying to make small
improvements to our position ultimate
goal
is to get the knight off of f6 if we can
so now bishop e3 he'll again play bishop
c5 so his bishop acts as kind of the
gatekeeper
but one thing we can try to do here is
um well we can try rookie three rook f3
but then he's gonna play bishop f4 again
um so let me think
okay let's hm let's push our pawn for
now let's get this pawn
to a square where it's more advanced and
we can protect that pawn with b3
and the idea of c4 b3 is dual what
idea do we have by playing this what
idea do we now have
it's appeared because as a consequence
of the move c4 bingo bishop b2
and finally it looks like he's gonna
have some trouble keeping that knight on
f6
now it might seem like no big deal to
you guys who might play g6 but g6 is a
very weakening move
that in and of itself creates potential
for tactics also we can just take the
pawn on h6
bishop b4 is super strong because now if
we if we play the ship e2 he meets it
with rook to d2
uh this guy is playing very very well
and
it's an honor to have viewers like these
on my stream but let's not forget about
an old idea
what old idea now seems to be quite
possible because his bishop no longer
has access to the f4 square
what what idea now becomes very
plausible
okay so bishop c5 he wants to meet
bishop b2 with bishop d4 man
not letting us get through but let's
tickle him with bishop f4
and okay let's repeat let's repeat moves
now we need to find a way to make
another marginal improvement to our
position
how do we make a marginal improvement
now one thing i want to make very clear
is that um okay we can go rookie five we
can centralize the rook
and we can tie his bishop down okay so
he blunters upon
and that was the idea my idea was to tie
his bishop down to the c5 square
to overload his bishop so that the
bishop could no longer gatekeep the
knight
okay rook two b and now we can get our
bishop out to a better square
his rook is kind of tied to the back
ring because if he moves it away
yeah that's right get back now can we
put this rock in a protected square
can we put this rope in a protected
square so we don't have to deal with or
we can be protected
we can protect it with a move before in
the interest of time we're gonna have to
play a little faster
now we can go rook b5 not rook a6 that
would have led into a discovery
oh that's a good move but here a little
tactic he's attacking two pieces at once
what can we do rogue takes b6 malcolm
you're the best there should be three
ah but he takes but now we have a
passport man this guy
play this game like a gm the queen e2
now
it's equal i missed that in the end but
in the time scramble
you have to make the decision that okay
now i'm going to play fast and he
blunders the knight
and finally and he blown his door so he
collapses here in the end amazing game
by exo stark that was a really really
interesting game in general it can teach
us a lot about positional play
good game your game sir
um okay so in time pressure heat
collapse in the end now
let's unpack this we're going to skip
the opening the opening was very normal
i got a slightly better position here it
just takes the queen back to d3
so in this position right every other
move would have a drawback we need 5
would walk into bishop d6
queen e2 or de1 would blood of the pawn
i could have considered sacking on e2
um queen f4 would block the development
of the bishop and walk into
d6 queen h4 would walk into bishop e7
creating a nasty pen
and if we unpin ourselves yeah i don't
want to create the situation right
so instead let me open up a new instance
of the game
we play queen d3 it does everything it
doesn't block the bishop it defends the
pawn
and it lets the rook occupy the open
file
h6 bishop d2 bishop f4
allows bishop d6 this is the thing a lot
of people they automatically choose
the most advanced square for the piece
that's what i want to get people not to
do as much of
especially at a higher level it's not
all about a piece controlling
maximum amount of squares you also need
to consider where your opponent is going
to put his pieces
and if there's something you want to try
to preserve such as the two bishops
that's exactly where a move like bishop
before could be bad because trading the
bishops
removes the two bishops on the board we
no longer have an advantage thank you
matt you're welcome
okay so he castles rook 81 welcome exo
start good great game man
amazing performance thanks
and um basically okay
so rook a1 bringing the rook and why
didn't i play rook f1 well to be honest
with you guys i thought that in the
future
i might have a plan associated with f4
f5
uh breaking down his e6 pawn and opening
up the diagonal for the bishop this by
the way is a very typical plan in these
positions
there is one small problem if we
actually go f4 here
which way is black going to castle and i
can even show you guys a game of mine
where i applied
this particular idea with a lot of
success against a good player
like this f4 f5 idea when the bishop is
on c4
you guys should consider castle's queen
side that's the good thing about being
flexible
that's the great and it's like going
second in a concert you know you're in a
piano concert
uh the first guy sets the bar and then
you know exactly where you can
how well or badly you can play uh that's
why i would never like to go first it's
the same principle here right we wait
for white to show his plan
and then we're like jokes on you you
weakened your king and f5 is not as
strong because black's king is not a g8
anymore he can just go e5
and uh the fact that the bishop is now
open is not as effective
does that kind of make sense so for that
reason uh
i kind of regretted this a little bit i
go a4
grabbing space rook d8 queen f3
now what is the rationale behind putting
the queen here
there's a very specific reason and that
reason connects with
stopping him from castling stopping him
from castling why
what tactic do we now have
well sacking my rook would not produce
sufficient attacking chances bishop h6
overloaded pawn i mean takes f6 once
upon
this is a simple overloading sacrifice
so he drops his bishop back
i was quite impressed with exo stark's
ability to detect tactics here he didn't
miss any of this
now we go c3 defending the knight
defending the pawn
queen a5 now bishop b3
this is where i think i made a mistake i
think in retrospect
it might have been a good idea to sack
the spawn play a move such as rookie
five
basically go for uh basically go for a
position like this where his queen is
out of the game
and um awesome marches major congrats
fantastic getting into mit is no
laughing matter
that's awesome then uh and very happy
for you
glad you're celebrating by accompanying
me on the stream
basically uh this produces some
compensation
i i honestly missed the move queen b6
now we have to drop our queen back and
precisely at this moment he opens up the
center
which leads to a pin now if we escape
the pin immediately he has rook takes d2
the queen is overloaded and he's got two
pieces for a rook
for that reason we have to defend the
bishop first now we bring the queen away
rook d7 bishop a2 deploying the bishop
to b1 now is the next stage
of the game the battle here revolves
around whether we'll be able to get his
knight out of f6
every single move in the next 20 moves
revolves around whether i can get this
knight away
that's what i'm trying to do with bishop
f4 he stops me with bishop d6 stops me
with bishop c5 otherwise bishop d4
bishop c1 and i decided okay let me keep
this bishop here
find a new way to do it we get our rook
to a good square
b5 i thought was a little unnecessary
because it allows us to create a
passpond
which we advance and the reason we
advance it is also because of bishop b2
is now an idea our opponent stops it by
getting active
if bishop b2 then bishop d4 you guys can
see like we're both trying to posture
her position
and um he's kind of keeping the gate
closed
to his knight this is where i think i
found a very nice move rook e5
um rookie five kind of pins his bishop
to his pawn
activates my rook and he blunders with
bishop of d4
what should a black of which black i've
done maybe bishop b4 i think that
now the rook obstructs our path to the
knight this is completely fine for black
probably quite equal and after rook
takes a5
bishop f4 uh a blunder by me rook v5
allowing this fork
and i i should have probably not gone
before kept the pawn chain attacked and
just gone rook b5
enjoyed my extra pawn uh and
uh yeah why is up upon here black is not
in any huge trouble i mean the game
continues
but v4 created a weakness on c4 that's a
type 2 undefeated pawn
which he immediately immediately
exploits and ultimately i forgot that he
can take the pawn
black is completely fine here it's a
drawn position and it's just unfortunate
that finally in temperature xo blunders
with g6
i think black can go knight d7 or
something and go knight e5 and
uh black is black is on the positive end
of a draw here so
why was pawn 85 such a good move i
mentioned it was good in the game
um the reason this one was good well
let's say he doesn't play fight let's
see he plays e6
could somebody string together a
sequence of moves remember what the
battle revolves around
watch you guys five bucks from young
turns thank you remember what the battle
revolves around
don't worry uh the battle revolves
around me trying to get my bishop
to one of these two squares and that
would allow me to do the b4 knocks the
bishop away from c5
and now what becomes possible again pay
attention think about the ultimate goal
here
bishop where there should be three
bishop d4 bingo
and black is in trouble because i kind
of want to take in goku nation that's
not the end of the world
but this creates a lot of pressure on
black now if he goes g6
uh i talked about this move weakening
his position what specifically
becomes possibly here white has a
beautiful tactical idea
uh that exploits the fact that this f7
pawn is overloaded people should see
that
this pawn is overloaded it's defending
two other pawns
and we can exploit that with a rucksack
this idea is quite typical i can find
you many many
instances of exactly this kind of tactic
appearing on the board in fact
i can do that right now i can find
something very very similar
in in some game um
using chessbase's position search
feature here's a good example
of that happening one second
okay now you should see the game so
this is just a random game uh but
hold my beer yeah but essentially what
does black i want somebody to find
white's move in this position first and
foremost
what is white's move here i qualify yes
yeah this should be one first and black
goes g6
now what should you notice in this
position what possibility should you
notice
and and that doesn't mean you should
make that move
but you should at least be aware that
the possibility of rook takes e6 exists
b takes a5 by mr schmidt super clever
move
look at this little rascal ah i
blundered a3 oh my god
jokes on you rook take c6 black waters
what should black have done in this
position instead how should black have
permanently ended this idea
and rook takes c6 up a piece and white
won the game
bishop f5 is correct so awareness
is one of the keys to tactical success a
lot of people solve problems and they
say i still blunder
i still miss this stuff well you also
need to set you need to open up that
metal detector
you need to make observations before a
tactic happens
that allows you to prevent blunders
right if you've noted to yourself ah i
need to watch for this on every move
at least for a couple seconds you're
less likely to miss me takes a3
rook takes c6 and y wins very simple
but uh nonetheless quite instructive
okay now you guys will not forget this
idea
so this is similar okay so that's why a5
is good
and uh there were more there's more to
talk about in this game but i also want
to keep things dynamic
i hope that this more or less makes
sense
yeah why didn't checkmate him um oh yeah
can i show the checkmate after the
rucksack
let me just show you guys another
example of this perhaps a little bit
less um
ah let me show you guys a slightly
different variation on the theme
game between two very good players 2200
against 2200
white to move who can find the move for
me take your time guys
i need to take another i need to pee
again i just had a
jar of coffee now i'm peeing
and i'll grab some more water so give me
a moment guys i'll be right back
what's the move e6 is the move okay
we want to disattach the f7 pawn from
the g6
and look up even further we got more
subs let's look at the
let's look at the move so the idea of
the movie stakes is to disattach yeah
let me
let me finish the water
i forgot to get water oh my god uh dis
attached the f7 problem from these six
months to
the roof take c6 rookie 6 fp6 we need to
combine two concepts back to the game
guys thank you so much to siebes
appreciate it and just part with the
prime
we need to we need to combine two
concepts i've talked about
concept number one is the wish list
what do we want to achieve from a
general perspective
like what is the general thing that we
want to have happen
now we need to understand how we need to
go about this a lot of people are saying
the most tempting word which is knight
h6
but white finds i think the best way to
instantiate this
because here's the thing the bishop is a
nice defender if we go into h6 and you
calculate this
it's actually not that simple after
bishop g7 there is no direct checkmate
so what loudoner thinks is okay i need
to do this but i need to get the bishop
away from f8
and so how do we do that and i need to
play with tempo you can't just go
anywhere
bingo you guys see the logic behind this
now if black takes
the king is a lot more alone and so the
move bishop takes g5 creates unstoppable
threats against black schema here here
this is just completely winning so
basically uh frosh ghost queen f6 gives
up a piece and he lost
ultimately that is what black has to do
but 96
is the concept of finding the best
execution
right finding the best execution
knight h6 97 check by the way also bad
because it gets lets the queen into the
defense
so very very precise play and that's
another
way to instantiate these concepts but
let's go back to the speedrun i know
everybody's anxious for the next game
the finish after bishop d6 well i mean
why not knight d6 first well because
because remember
you haven't completed the aim of
disattaching this pawn from this pawn
so black can just take the knight the
move over here is really important
charlie and i will be
talking about that on monday yeah so how
exactly does checkmate happen here well
for example
if this should be seven then that covers
the escape square this is made
if queen e8 then we go queen h6
and i call this kind of rolling out the
red carpet what do we roll the red car
actually we don't even need the red
carpet we just made it like this
bishop h7 was also possible if king f7
here
then bishop g6 wins um could you have
gone knight d6 before e6
no because bishop takes d6 and again
this position is good for white but it's
not winning
right does that make sense if you go e6
now remember as my coach would say this
isn't checkers black doesn't need to
take anymore
knight f8 black defends the pawn black
is up a piece
yeah i know that's what you guys are
thinking but remember taking is not
forced
here taking is a lot more forced because
white is also going ef
and uh and this is just crushing you
know that makes sense
okay uh let's get back unless there are
any more questions let's get back into
the speed run
another huge shout out 50 gifted from t
seeds
and uh yeah
knight just uh gets out
well what about gf yeah so gf um well
basically
white achieves the same effect here of
weakening black's king so i think he
takes f5 is the idea
composition one and two thank you and
after knight f6 queen g6 is checkmate
because the rook
obstructs the queen the king's escape
thanks for another sub levy invented the
phrase well this it's a russian phrase
and
levy did not invent it i didn't invent
it it's existed for many many years
it's like a typical russian chess phrase
this is also made you just drive the
king into the corner
and you checkmate him like this um
okay so the rook sack okay guys let's
move on
i've already shown the mate after the
rook sec
what yeah i know there are specific
questions but i think you guys get the
gist of it at the new strategy
i think you guys get the gist of the
line i don't want to bog ourselves down
too much
into the actual uh sort of the the
details
[Music]